-Our next guest is a talente
actor you know from his work
on the "Captain America"
and "Avengers" movies.
He returns as Bucky Barnes
in "The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier,"
which is available
exclusively on Disney Plus
with new episodes
releasing on Fridays.
Let's take a look.
-You're alone.
You're 100 years old.
You have no history,
no family --
-Are you lashing out at me, Doc?
Because that's really
unprofessional.
You know, I mean,
when did that start?
When'd you start yelling
at your clients?
Oh, the notebook. That's great
[ Sighs ]
All right. Give me a break
I'm trying. Okay?
This isn't -- [ Sighs ]
This is new for me.
I didn't have a moment
to deal with anything.
You know?
I had a little...calm.
In Wakanda.
And other than that, I jus
went from one fight to another
for 90 years.
-Please welcome to the sho
Sebastian Stan.
Thanks for being here,
Sebastian.
-Hey, man,
thank you for having me.
-I feel like
there were two things
we were all very desperate for
over the last year --
vaccines and new Marvel content.
And it feels like
they're dovetailing together
very nicely.
-Yes. Yes.
Perfect timing for both of us,
I guess.
-So, I have to ask,
when you and your co-star
Anthony Mackie were --
this was first presented to you,
was it surprising?
Did you know
this project was coming?
-No, we didn't.
We just both knew
we were going to stick aroun
in some capacity.
You know, because we were aliv
at the end of "Endgame."
But, then, we had both gotte
called in, unbeknownst to us
you know, for a meeting.
And, you know,
we had separate meetings,
but then I ran into him
at this hotel in L.A.,
and I didn't know
he was in L.A.
And he, like,
looked at me funny,
and I looked at him funny,
and we sort of started
to kind of
piece the puzzle together
that maybe we were there
for the same reason, you know?
-One of the puzzles
anybody in show business
has had to piece together
this year
is how to shoot during COVID
obviously.
-Yeah.
-You were --
In the middle of it, you wer
going to Prague last March
-It's very difficult
with Anthony
because he's a close talker.
So, you know, the aspect
of social distance for him
is a difficult thing.
But, yeah, we were in Prague
-It's like a normal 6 feet, bu
it's like an Anthony 12 feet
Is that what you're saying
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, exactly.
-So, you flew to Prague.
This was, I guess, last year
Before everything shut down.
And I will say I tip my cap.
Early on, you were
taking this very serious.
That's you on an airplane.
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, well, thank God Fox News
reported on it at the time
you know?
But we did because, you know
we didn't know what to expect.
And I had my best friend
with me,
who's a worse hypochondria
than I was.
And we just kept piling things
on and going --
I mean, where do we stop
with this thing?
And, you know,
it was our first --
my first picture of this hashtag
we were trying out
called #BuckyTakesEurope,
Which, of course,
led to only three posts
and a birthday that happened
a few days later.
And then we were sent back
-I heard you were
actually celebrating
Bucky's 106th birthday
when you found out
that everything was shut down.
-Yep. Yeah.
We were -- We decided to fin
one of the most authentic,
you know, places in Prague
to go and have dinner,
and it was a crowded place
And we thought
it was funny at the time,
and then it led to me
meeting about 35 waiters
and hugging them
and taking selfies with them
and then, 10 minutes later
we got a call.
We were supposed to
get on a plane.
So I felt really good
about how I spent that night..
more at risk than ever.
-Now, I have to ask,
you know, obviously,
you're not Bucky's age yet
but you have been playing
this character for 10 years.
Is it harder --
Do you find the recovery harde
from the intense
action sequences
that they put
your character through?
-Yes. Well, it's usually
by the end of the press tour
so you can get closer
and closer to the age.
But, yeah.
I mean, I think we both
take quite a lot of Advil,
you know, and there's --
and definitely some ice packs.
But, you know, it's just -
We got to get Anthony
off the ground a lot more.
-[ Laughs ] That's right.
Very nice how I feel like
you have a lot of empathy
for Anthony.
It's really sweet that you'r
sharing that with us today
-Well, I do, you know,
but it's sort of something
you have to live with.
It's like --
You know, it's like a diseas
that you're just gonna
have to live with.
But we --
I think, look, you know,
we kind of know each other wel
and we have a good rapport
and somehow they decided
to give us a show,
you know, to have more,
so it's been a privilege.
-You came back from Prague
when everything got shut dow
in New York City.
I know that you had
lived here before.
You were an actor
here in New York City.
What was it like for you
last spring being in a cit
that obviously we all know
is much more vibrant
than it was then?
-Well, it was really strange
I mean, because, you know,
we didn't really know what -
at the time what to expect
And so everything
felt out of place.
And, you know, I think
the emptiness of the streets
But I went full on like
"The Aviator" DiCaprio OCD
Like, I was taking
my clothes off in my hallway
and running them
to the washing machine
and then washing every littl
thing, you know, in the sink
And it was really weird.
But I had this old lady
across the street from me
who every night at 7:00 p.m.
would come out
and just blast Frank Sinatra
You know, and then,
everybody else would come ou
and just sort of join in.
And that -- Moments like tha
just feel kind of that --
They surpass all time.
-I always like asking
anybody who was young
living in New York,
especially actors,
what their first -- their
early apartments were like
Did you have any doozies
back in your day?
-It was --
I'll say exactly where it was.
It was at 323 West 42nd Street
right across
from Port Authority.
-Oh, great area. Great area.
Beautiful.
-Yeah. Yeah.
But we were in Times Square.
So, you know, we felt lucky.
-How many roommates
were you rocking back then
-Uh, well, I had
one official roommate
that paid the rent with me
and then we had all of our
Rutgers friends kind of, like,
just hop off the bus,
cross the street,
and then crash with us,
you know?
But it was -- I don't know
Everything about that
was romantic at the time.
That's what we said to ourselves
until you walked outside.
-Yeah. And you would also,
I'm sure, say it to girls.
"You want to see
something romantic?
You've never seen romance
until you've seen
the Port Authority at night.
-Oh, yes. Yeah. Yeah.
That will definitely
shake things up.
-It's like the one neighborhoo
they just haven't tried
giving a cute name to.
They're like, "No."
"We've got a one-bedroom
in Port Thor."
-Yeah. Yeah.
It's always what it is.
But in a way, you know,
there was something
grounding about it.
And it's like --
You walk out in New York City.
You know, you're always --
Life greets you,
and it kind of puts you on a -
reminds you
of the right things I guess.
-I think
you're right about that.
And congrats on the show.
It's so exciting to watch.
And thanks so much
for being here.
-Thank you. Thank you, man
Absolutely. Thanks so much
I'll see you.
-New episodes of "The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier"
are available on Fridays
exclusively on Disney Plus